Tesla faces a crucial test today with
the release of new production numbers
for its highly touted model 3 the stakes
are especially high because a deadly
accident involving Tesla's autopilot
feature is under federal investigation
the company is also recalling 123
thousand Model S cars Jamie yuccas is at
a Tesla dealership in Santa Monica
California Jamie good morning good
morning
Tesla put all of its considerable
high-tech know-how behind its least
expensive car the model 3
but the rollout has been plagued with
production problems and analysts say the
corporate outlook won't improve until
output does Tesla's Model 3 was designed
to bring battery-powered luxury to the
masses recently named Popular Mechanics
car of the year it is more than 500,000
pre-orders but meeting that demand has
been an uphill battle we're building the
cars as fast as we can at a special
model 3 presentation last July
Tesla founder Elon Musk displayed a
charge projecting production at five
thousand cars a week by the end of 2017
but in the last seven working days of
last year they produced fewer than eight
hundred vehicles they revised their goal
down to about 2,500 a week by the end of
March but a reported leaked email from
musk on Monday said that number is
closer to 2000 delivery delays have hurt
sales and cash flow contributing to a
downturn in stock prices Tesla shares
are down 19 percent since the beginning
of the year about 40,000 for this one
yeah a little bit over Auto analyst
Jessica Caldwell says for Tesla the
model 3 is more than just another call
and this is supposed to be their
moneymaker this is their moneymaker this
is what's gonna fund the rest of the
company moving forward this is supposed
to sell millions and you know there's
definitely some some roadblocks there
right now musk is now apparently
overseeing production first hand
tweeting I'm back to sleeping at factory
car biz is how the production problems
come as Tesla is facing other corporate
challenges federal investigators are
looking into last month's deadly crash
in California
involving a Model X driving in autopilot
mode Tesla says the driver receives
several visual and audible warnings but
their hands were not detected on the
wheel six seconds prior to the collision
the company is also recalling a hundred
and twenty three thousand Model S sedans
to fix a steering problem it's not a
good time for the company right now and
I think they need to instill some
confidence and people to say that we can
actually do this and production is the
one thing that can do that Tesla blames
a Nevada battery company for its
production holdups but says the problems
there have been fixed they hope that
people look at the big picture of the
company and say that the model 3 will be
its most successful car yet John alright
Jamie thanks it's a little bit of a bump
for the company for sure right now but I
would not bet against Elon Musk
those EPA emission standards are gonna
hurt Tesla to do again I still wouldn't
bet against I think he's got some plans
we'll see